as summer approaches and temperatures
rise
the beaches in rio de janeiro are
increasingly packed
and so are the intensive care units both
in public and private hospitals
ninety percent of them are occupied many
of them by younger patients
but that's not stopping countless others
who believe the covid19 pandemic is over
i'm no longer afraid of the coronavirus
nobody is
just look around ignoring social
distancing
and the use of masks is a risk that
comes at a high price
we are not prepared for the second wave
emergency field hospitals have been
dismantled
doctors say the existing hospitals in
rio de janeiro and sao paulo
are reaching their limit and may no
longer be able to cope
with the increasing number of infected
unless urgent
measures to stop them are taken we have
several colleagues medical doctors that
were
in the front working that got sick
and they are occupying intensive care
beds and so
so it means that we are having another
uh epidemic peak and and i am afraid i'm
really afraid
that december can bring to brazil the
second wave
so my personal feeling is that we'll
we are going to have a very sad
christmas
and beginning of the new year with 174
000 kovid 19 related deaths brazil has
the world's second largest number of
fatalities
after the united states but just as the
curve was beginning to flatten
there was a spike more and more young
people were seen in crowded bars and at
parties
and then there was the recent political
campaign for mayoral elections
in more than 5 000 cities nationwide
as soon as the november 29 municipal
elections were over
the governor of the state of sao paulo
announced new safety measures
we won't close down economic activities
but restrict them to avoid gatherings
as of now shops bars and restaurants
will only be able
to operate at 40 percent of their
capacity
and must close by 10 p.m
for some it may be too little too late
brazil still lacks a national policy for
dealing with the pandemic
so even for researchers working on the
vaccine
like margaret talcomo it's hard to
imagine what will happen
if government authorities and brazilians
themselves
don't take the necessary precautions
i don't know i don't know
i am praying i don't know money
experts say the best hope is still the
vaccine
but in the best case scenario mass
vaccination
in brazil is expected to start only
after march
of 2021. monica yanakiv
rio de janeiro al-jazeera